but you can look back through history
and you you get this you suddenly
realize that tax is power if a king or a
government or an emperor whoever the
leader is as as long as they control
that as soon as they lose their tax
revenue they lose their power taxation
is power it is control and you you when
you when you start to look at things
through that you know if you imagine if
governments today don't have the tax
revenue pretty quickly the whole thing
falls apart and you then think every war
in history was funded by some kind of
tax every single war you tax during the
event and then afterwards you know the
conquered territories would be plundered
and then taxed and often wars were
funded through debt but debt is just a
taxation on the future
I've regard debt as another form of
taxation every revolution has been of
rising up a revolt against some kind of
injustice perpetrated by the tax system
the most famous ones being the French
Revolution the American Civil War no
taxation without representation even the
Russian Revolution American Revolution
ya know that that was the the the the
u.s. American Revolution but even the
Russian Revolution no so you said
American Civil War that's what I'm sorry
the American Revolution and sorry that I
will always get the Russian Revolution
well well you're gonna know more about
it than I am
hi well ok but it was it was a it was an
overthrowing of serfdom effectively and
and serfdom was yet again a system of
taxing and rule serfs paid they didn't
necessarily pay cash but their labor was
owned and they paid their labor and
their labor was taken by their lords and
so on and and funnily enough quite
interesting serfdom was overthrown in
Western Europe the feudal system was
overthrown in Western Europe by the
Black Death because it killed what to
everyone out and suddenly there was a
shortage of labor and serfs were able to
demand their freedom and payment for
their labor and so even though you know
2/3 of the population was wiped out it
gave surfed and the freedom black death
never hit Russia in the same way that it
did Western Europe and so the culture
the the system remained and it took
you know the Russian Revolution to get
rid of it well there's a silver lining
to the coronavirus if two-thirds of us
are wiped out the rest of us might have
some better buy well yeah that is the
there is that argument but it's not
[Music]